we welcome you to cbs this morning we've
got lee exciting news because we begin
with a sign of hope from the united
kingdom in the global fight against this
pandemic
this morning a 90 a 90 year old woman
she's a grandmother she became the first
person
in the world to take the pfizer by in
tech vaccine outside of clinical trials
she'll be the first of millions and
that's according to the british
government plan
and the uk's rollout could be a model
for other countries
including our own where the fda has yet
to approve the vaccine
charlie dagetta is outside the hospital
in central england where the first dose
was given
charlie good morning to you
good morning to you this is a landmark
moment for the first time at this very
hospital
a person in the western world received
an approved covid 19 vaccine
here they're calling it v-day mass
vaccinations
have just begun it is the shot
seen around the world first on the globe
to receive it
ninety-year-old grandmother maggie
keenan made history
i would say go for it go for it because
it's
it's free and it's the best thing that's
ever happened
so do please go for it that's all i say
poetically second to go for it was
william shakespeare of warwickshire
even a 99 year old world war ii veteran
they're the first to be inoculated today
with the pfizer biontech vaccine which
was granted emergency approval here only
last week
the vaccine will initially be
administered from around 70
hospital hubs across the uk to people
over 80
and some front line health workers
before being rolled out to thousands of
temporary vaccine centers
including converted parking lots sports
stadiums even race courses
it's amazing to see this tremendous shot
in the arm for the entire nation
but we can't afford to relax now
not with a death toll of 61 000 and
climbing one of the highest in the world
per capita even higher than the us
the uk has ordered 40 million doses
enough for 20 million people
the u.s has an order in for a hundred
million doses pending fda approval
after shielding for many long months
maggie is now hoping to see her family
again in the new year
there may be a long road ahead but now
there's a root out
maggie will be back here in 21 days to
receive her second
shot she develops immunity or should
develop immunity about a week after that
and again this is the same kind of
rollout that you may be seeing in the
united states
in the coming days anthony very excited
to see that even if it's overseas
charlie thank you